to our other top story tonight for the
second time in less than a week
metro police responded to a shooting on
the las vegas strip
one person is dead tonight and two
others are hurt the latest case happened
early this morning
it comes after a wave of violent
incidents on las vegas boulevard
throughout 2020
madison kimbrough joins us live near las
vegas boulevard and harman avenue
with the latest details on this madison
yes this deadly shooting occurred around
three this morning and according to
police it all started between an
altercation with a group of men a
25-year-old malik frost
is in custody for this shooting he's
charged with murder and attempted murder
this all started in front of the
hawaiian marketplace on the las vegas
strip
at some point during that altercation
frost pulled out a handgun
and fired one shot at another man
killing him on the scene
after the shooting frost ran away on las
vegas boulevard
and was chased by two people
one of the males who was following the
suspect then
pulled a pulled something or picked up
something and threw it
at the suspect we think it's potentially
a rock
he then turned around and shot three
more times
striking the second person in the leg
that person was taken to the hospital
but is said to have non-life-threatening
injuries
another person was hit by a ricochet
bullet but they were treated at the
scene
frost was booked at clark county
detention center for open murder and
attempted murder
as of now it's still unclear how the
relationship of all of those
involved in the shooting how they are
related but we will keep you posted as
we learn the latest
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now